a well-known fertility clinic in Central
Delhi it's helped deliver over eight
thousand babies over the last two
decades using assisted reproduction
techniques as well as surrogacy you
don't worry now my god making founder
dr. Anubha Gupta a highly sought-after
figure in his field this couple i heard
to have a baby using a surrogate mother
it's highly confidential even their own
families don't know about it and they
don't want to be identified on camera
the couple already have a five-year-old
son but the woman who is 38 is unable
medically to bear for the children it's
not a question of convenient or non
conveying another woman to do it was the
answer see you have something you know
like dream when you marry you Caleb two
kids one kids or whatever you know and
if that is not fulfilled some time you
feel whatever you think you know if it
doesn't happen then you know you go for
alternatives also if there is some
product like she has trouble my name is
you Taylor so it'll be more fulfilling
you know if the dream what we saw
together if it comes true dreams that
are fulfilled by women like wrinkles the
23 year old from West Bengal is a
surrogate mother for a childless couple
in Delhi she's still in the early days
of her pregnancy rinku who also doesn't
want to be identified in camera stands
to earn a little over four thousand five
hundred dollars that's as much as a
husband makes in three years as a
rickshaw driver in the city she says it
would go a long way towards paying for a
young son's education hi Malika Nia
could but Jackie Lee I'm doing this for
my own child I want to give him a better
future and I think this will help not
just me but also someone else who was
desperate for the joy of having a baby
but all that may come to an abrupt end
if the indian parliament approves the
draft will completely manning commercial
surrogacy only so-called altruistic
surrogacy would be allowed for indian
couples married at least five years and
only a close relative would be allowed
to bear the child it's something dr.
Gupta thinks cannot work in india given
the stigma attached to infertility he
says women opting for surrogate babies
often where silicon
is under the clothing to fake pregnancy
in India the confidentiality is required
in surrogacy you know it's like a
bedroom scenario even the couple will
not disclose to their parents that they
are going through this because it is not
considered good it you know it is you
know female gets demoralized and every
female wants to carry their own baby so
when they do surrogacy also they want to
show that they are pregnant and even you
know to the nearest of kin and you know
they want they don't want to show that
it's surrogacy then how come a relative
you know can come and do it the desire
to have offspring and the opportunity
for poor women to earn good money that's
what's been driving surrogacy but it
looks as the India's government could
soon be pulling the emergency brake on
what until now has been a thriving
industry